- [Narrator] The U.S. and China,
are two of the world's
biggest cotton producers.
The U.S. exports most of its cotton
and its biggest customer is China.
Which bought nearly $3 billion
of American cotton last year.
At the same time, China
exports the largest share
of its finished textiles to the U.S.,
but the balance of that
relationship is shifting.
In 2021, president Joe Biden
signed a law banning imports from China's
main cotton growing region Xinjiang.
Home of millions of Uyghurs
and other ethnic minorities.
Human rights groups have accused China
of detaining as many as 1 million people
and forcing them into labor,
which China has repeatedly denied
- The impact of banning this
cotton in China can't be overstated.
- [Narrator] U.S. cotton prices surged,
after many American companies
scrambled for new cotton sources.
China even started importing
more American cotton
since lots of its domestic supply,
couldn't be used for
goods sent to the U.S..
But now those imports have been declining.
This comes at a time
when U.S. cotton farmers
were already struggling
due to lower prices and drought.
And because China is so enmeshed
in the cotton supply chain
plenty of Xinjiang cotton
is still making it into the U.S.,
according to companies
that do forensic testing
of cotton apparel.
Here's how the U.S. effort
to stamp out forced labor
has impacted the cotton
market in both countries.
The U.S. grows about 12%
of the world's cotton.
China grows more than
double that, about 26%.
And China isn't just
the world's biggest grower of cotton,
it's a key processor of it too.
- The garment processing
textile processing industry
really isn't based that much
in the United States anymore.
So it goes overseas China
is a big destination
but then you also have Bangladesh,
Vietnam, Sri Lanka.
- [Narrator] According to
estimates from December, 2022,
China milled about 35.5
million bales of cotton.
Last year, the U.S. milled
about 2.3 million bales.
China has remained a key player
in the cotton supply chain
but its role has been shifting.
More and more other countries
like Vietnam, Pakistan
and Bangladesh have been
importing raw cotton,
milling it into yarn,
and then sending the yarn to China.
- It is kind of tough to know
where exactly your cotton is coming from.
I think the way that a lot
of these facilities work
it's really tough to audit whether or not,
a Chinese mill, for example,
is using cotton that comes from Xinjiang
or from elsewhere in the world.
- [Narrator] As cotton gets cleaned,
purified and finished
via a complicated supply chain,
it becomes harder and harder to know
where the original cotton came from,
which makes it easier
for companies to dodge
import restrictions.
Then there's the final
stage of the process,
using yarn or fabric to
make the finished goods.
China also leads here.
U.S. trade statistics suggest
U.S. imports of cotton products from China
have decreased over the last decade.
Though the country is
still the biggest source
of U.S. cotton textiles and apparel.
The U.S. meanwhile makes few
of its own finished goods.
One trade group found
less than 3% of apparel
sold in the U.S. last year
was produced domestically.
Though those figures
weren't specific to cotton.
- We live in a hyper globally
competitive marketplace.
You've seen a decimation
of critical aspects of our industry.
- [Narrator] Kim Glas
is the president and CEO
of the National Council
of Textile Organizations,
which represents domestic manufacturers.
She says goods made by
forced labor in China
make it impossible for
American businesses to compete.
- In the cotton supply chain,
it's pennies that moves
and shifts production globally
from one country to another.
And particularly on the areas of Xinjiang
and Forced labor associated
with those cotton supply chains
that has had a severe economic impact
on the U.S. domestic textile industry.
- [Narrator] Importers have
to document the products
they're bringing into the U.S.,
but this doesn't always
tell the whole story.
U.S. Customs and Border Protection
detains some goods that
its risk assessment tools
flag as potentially illegal,
and importers are required to present
additional documentation
to get them released.
But some like Glas, say enforcement
of the ban has been insufficient.
- The numbers are completely underwhelming
on enforcement activities.
A few dozen shipments stopped per month.
We're talking about thousands
and millions of packages coming in
that contain apparel items.
We should be seeing stop shipments
off the port of LA, every day.
- [Narrator] The clearest way to know
where an item comes from,
is to test its chemical
components and DNA.
Customs test some imports,
but many companies also do their own
to validate their supply chains.
- Cotton is a plant and it has to,
just like you and I, take in nutrients,
so you can analyze those nutrients
to get an idea of where
the plant was grown.
- [Narrator] Applied DNA Sciences
is a biotech company based
on Long Island.
It specializes in supply chain tracing
as well as genetic
testing and therapeutics.
- We have two different
colors of the same shirt
submitted by the same client,
both claimed to be from Brazil.
One of them tested clearly
as being from Brazil
and it matched with our
library Brazilian samples
while the other one matched with Xinjiang.
And there would be no
way on a rack to tell,
they would be right next to each other
a black and a white shirt.
- [Narrator] They also do DNA tagging
spraying a molecular tag onto raw fibers
at the cotton gen,
so companies can track their raw cotton
through the supply chain.
- About 14 or 15% of the finished foods
we test show evidence of Xinjiang cotton.
We tell the people who've
asked us to test that product
and then they have to push
harder on their supply chain.
- [Narrator] Given the complexity of
ensuring goods from China
don't contain Xinjiang cotton,
retailers like L.L Bean and Mango
have cut out China completely.
- You see brands moving their operations
to get around China in general,
'cause they don't wanna
run into a situation
where they can't sell in the U.S.
You see them moving these companies
moving their supply chains out of China
to places like Vietnam,
or Bangladesh, Sri Lanka.
You know all the names that you see
when you look at the back of your shirt.
- [Narrator] But this is missing
a major part of the story.
According to experts, many of these goods
may have been processed
or even made in China
but are being exported to
the U.S. via another country.
Another thing, trade data misses
is a loophole that many industry experts
say allows China to ship goods
containing banned cotton into the U.S..
A huge number of shipments from China
arrive through a rule called de minimis,
which allows shipments worth under $800
to come into the U.S.
without incurring tariffs
or requiring as much paperwork.
This is significantly
higher than the de minimis
limit for imports to China,
which is just 50 yuan, less than $7.
Some lawmakers are trying
to modify this rule
to keep ban Chinese cotton out
and level the playing field
for U.S. cotton growers
who have already been dealing
with decreasing prices and drought.
The Uyghur Forced Labor Protection Act
is ultimately designed to
clamp down on forced labor
but it also has major bearings
on the U.S. cotton industry.
- Theoretically, when the
ban first came into place
U.S. cotton growers were really hoping
that that would give
cotton prices in general,
a boost would give export demand a boost
which it has to some extent.
- [Narrator] But ultimately
it hasn't been enough,
at least so far,
to offset the long-term decline
of the U.S. cotton industry.
(upbeat music)